[Music]
humans are odd
they think order and chaos are somehow
opposites and
try to control what won't be
but a thing isn't beautiful because it
lasts
vision what do you want
[Music]
for people to see you as i do
tell me what you feel
i just feel you
happy new year everyone welcome back
this is going to be my marvel legends
episode 1 video for one division i'll
explain what's going on and how this all
ties in
and what they're doing with the extra
content for the one division episodes
and i will be doing videos for all the
one division episodes starting next week
as well so be sure to subscribe if
you're brand new to my channel
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just leave all
your predictions for x-men stuff
during the one division series so if you
have no idea what's going on with this
they just dropped a trailer they didn't
really promote this during the big
disney plus investor meeting with the
loki trailer and all the other big
trailers and teasers they released like
thor 4 love and thunder the fantastic
four movie they just announced there
were so many things that they announced
at that disney plus investor meeting no
surprise that they left some of it on
the floor
but the way they're treating this is
sort of like bonus content
for the shows that they're billing as
its own show so marvel legends is like
its own show on disney plus but they're
doing episodes like this
for all the different marvel phase four
projects they didn't say if they're
doing it for all the movies like if
they'll drop a black widow episode
before the black widow movie comes out
in may but it sounds like they're at
least doing it for the disney plus
series
so when they get ready to release the
falcon and winter soldier episodes in
march they'll drop marvel legends
episodes for both falcon and winter
soldier
same thing for loki but had the virus
not delayed everything i have a feeling
they probably would have turned this
into a bigger show with more narration
and footage from the actors talking
about their characters
but the other new shows that marvel's
doing for the marvel phase 4
projects that they didn't announce at
the disney plus investor meeting
include disney gallery episodes for all
the marvel series just like they did for
the mandalorian season 1 and season 2.
those are the episodes where they do a
much bigger version of what you probably
thought that this marvel legends series
was going to be
because all these marvel phase 4 series
are basically like a 150 million dollar
movie
just turned into a tv series with six to
nine or ten episodes just depending
because the other big surprise is that
one division is going to have nine
episodes total even though they're
dropping the first two
together next week i'll explain what's
going on with that too
paul bettany claims that there are more
visual effects shots in one division
than in all of avengers end game which
sounds like a bit of a surprise
in that the whole decades of sitcom
thing obviously that we've seen in all
the trailers in the episodes
only last for a little while before the
show actually turns into a much bigger
traditional
avengers storyline so for those of you
that aren't big fans of sitcoms in
general or you just don't follow the
logic with what they're doing with some
of these episodes in the meta easter
eggs
the show will turn into more of a
traditional big marvel production that
you would expect from one of the marvel
movies
by the end of the series the whole thing
with them blowing through the decades of
sitcoms is mostly just a deal with the
house of m
easter eggs mutants coming into the mcu
in a big way the x-men characters
and her twin children billy and tommy
that you actually see during the
trailers
it's only one of the ways that they're
bringing x-men into the mcu now that
they have control of those characters
but because they want to have their cake
and eat it too so to speak they want to
do the story line where they give birth
to their children like they actually
have that family
but they also want to have those kids be
adults so they can actually do really
cool
avengers level stuff they have to age
them up so that's why they're aging
through the decades of television like
as you go through the different decades
the kids get bigger and bigger and
bigger until the end of the series when
they'll probably be teenagers
that's also part of the reason why i
think they're releasing the first two
episodes
at the same time next week instead of
waiting another week to drop
episode two just to burn through the
black and white era of television faster
so people don't get super confused with
the whole sitcom trope like why is it
like this
it feels kind of weird like if you've
never watched nick at night or you never
watch i love lucy or any of those
classic tv shows
you'd probably be pretty confused if you
walked into this cold the other cool
house of m thing that was going on
recently elizabeth olsen was just
talking about that story line in her own
words she implied that when she was
first cast as scarlet witch for avengers
age of ultron that was one of the comics
that they gave her to check out
and it became one of her favorites like
she had really wanted to do that
storyline for a long time
but never thought that they would ever
be able to do it just because of the
whole right situation with the x-men
being at fox
i've always been hungry to lean into the
comic book stories
that we're leaning into in this show and
i didn't know if i'd have the
opportunity
to explore it which is the reason why i
wanted to be a part of
the avengers to begin with when joss
asked me to he said look at these comics
and tell me if you are interested and
those specific comics are the ones that
feige said
this is what our show is going to be
about for one division the whole theory
about why they're doing
mcu house of m through wand division is
like i said
incorporating the x-men into the mcu
heading into marvel phase four marvel
phase five before they actually do their
full-blown
rebooted mcu x-men film obviously they
announced the fantastic four film is
coming first
i think the reason for that is just to
give an extra cooling off period because
it's so
soon after the fox x-men movies in dark
phoenix just went down so bad for so
many people
so most of those characters are going to
be recast eventually
and fantastic four unlike the x-men
movies
has never really had a solid movie
before so they have much more need for a
desperate really big splashy reboot
in a solid film finally i'm sure chris
evans is going to be posting all kinds
of memes when they eventually release
that fantastic four film
the really cool thing about scarlet
witch that a lot of you will know if
you've been following a lot of the extra
mcu stuff the tie-in material
is that a long time ago they actually
confirmed that the mine stone didn't
give her
her powers it merely unlocked powers
that were already there so that was them
just laying the seeds
for them to reveal that she's been a
mutant this whole time
they've been doing that since the marvel
phase 1 movies kevin feige and the
marvel people just sort of writing in
x-men easter eggs and mutant easter eggs
in the background
so that when eventually they did work up
to a big crossover with x-men characters
they could say they've been here this
whole time see we've been planning it
this whole time
there's even the iron man movie post
credit scene that got deleted early on
where nick fury directly references
mutants that's how early goes back to
the very first mcu film
as if gamma accidents radioactive bug
bites and assorted mutants weren't
enough
i have to deal with a spoiled brat who
doesn't play well with others and wants
to keep all his toys to himself
you notice that he also mentions
spider-man during that so you have to
keep in mind that that was happening
before they had rebooted with the andrew
garfield amazing spider-man franchise
way before tom holland so at the time
the spider-man that he was speaking of
in that reference was the tobey maguire
spider-man
and it sounds like if all this crossover
spider-verse stuff works out for
spider-man 3
they're actually going to be able to pay
that off finally the other big way
they're incorporating the x-men
characters into the mcu going forward is
just straight-up multiverse alternate
universes explainer like literally
characters legacy actors who still play
their characters from the fox x-men
films
crossing over into future marvel movies
so like if james mcavoy or michael
fassbender want a cameo
they can actually do that and just say
they came from an alternate reality
pretty straight up easy explainer
the whole thing with one division though
is it is then taking her full comic book
x-men scarlet witch where she can legit
warp reality
around her it's sort of the mcu version
of her chaos magic
where hopefully they build up to a
situation at the end of the series where
she wants to keep her children she
doesn't want to let go of them because
she created them in this alternate
reality
where she tries to merge that fake
reality or aspects of it with the main
mcu reality
that's really where you have big doctor
strange two stuff getting involved
because you have blending of alternate
realities
and as he said doctor strange's number
one priority
is protecting the fidelity of our
reality the main
mcu reality that's why during the one
division series
just like the history of the scarlet
witch character in the comics
she's been both a villain and both an
ally to the avengers she's normally
viewed as a good character so she's not
really a villain in the traditional
sense more of an antagonist at times
they're doing that with the scarlet
witch character during the one division
series where she winds up causing
a lot of the problems that they do have
to solve during the series
my episode videos will post every friday
it'll be the same schedule as the
mandalorian
i'm still working on a new loki series
video they just made a couple really big
really cool announcements about what's
going on with the future of that series
and obviously that's going to be
crossing over with thor for love and
thunder
so while you wait for that click here
for that brand new teaser that they
released for thor 4 love and thunder and
learn about christian bale's character
and click here for that big scene from
one division episode 1 that they just
released
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and happy new year
[Music]
you